Speaker 1: they are thinking about investigating
Hillary Clinton. Do not adjust your television.
Do not go back 15 seconds on your podcast player.
It is May of 20, 23. And they are looking at an
investigation into Bill and Hillary Clinton. Jim
Jordan appeared standing and with no suit jacket,
as he always does on Maria BARTIROMO Show
yesterday morning on Fox News. Maria BARTIROMO
is a Fox News propagandist and Trump brown noser
who screams most of the show. I don't know why
you could just turn up the microphone if
you thought she needed more volume and
she gets Jim Jordan to seemingly tease that
they're going to look into an investigation
into Hillary and maybe Bill Clinton as
well as you can see. House Republicans,
since taking control in January, they
really have their fingers on the pulse of
the issues of importance to the American people.
Speaker 2: Real quick, do you want to see another
investigation of Hillary and Bill Clinton? Because
in the Durham report, John Durham wrote that
while they were pursuing Trump, they made no
effort to investigate the claim that Hillary
Clinton was taking money from foreigners for
writing a global initiative and the Clinton
Foundation.
Speaker 3:
They not only did they investigate her
like they did President Trump, they gave.
Speaker 1: Her are they're both screaming today.
Speaker 3: And paying a defensive briefing. Right.
They should have done the same for President Trump
because they literally had no evidence. So we're
going to talk with our lawyers, going to talk
with Speaker McCarthy on where we proceed from,
from here, in fact. Are there people that
were that were highlighted in the Durham
investigation and the Durham report that we
need to talk to on the Judiciary Committee?
We're going to give that a good hard look.
But nothing is off the table because it is.
Speaker 1: Even Hillary is on the table.
Speaker 3: The American people understand
how their government, their agencies
have been turned on them, the taxpayer.
And we get all the facts out there.
Speaker 2: Mr. Chairman, real quick.
Speaker 1: I hope they finally get to the
bottom of the Lewinsky scandal. I really do,
because I've been waiting around. Nobody's really
given it a good hard look. And I think it's time
that we figure out what the hell happened back
in the nineties with Bill Clinton, maybe go back
even further. I want them to look at some of the
things that Hillary did when Bill was governor
of Arkansas, because I think that's really where
the bodies are buried, as they love to say these
people are nuts, but I wouldn't put it past
them to actually try to investigate Hillary.